foreign
[Music]
there's a power in belief
my family always used to say responder
believing is power
so when I would see magazines of you
know white fly fishermen in Yellowstone
I did believe that
it would be me one day
leaving home for me has been really hard
we used to do everything together
now I'm trying to do that on my own and
it's different because conservation fly
fishing mountaineering it's very solo
I don't hear my brother's laughing
I don't hear my sisters yelling at each
other
I don't hear my mom and dad
[Music]
it's hard to even now explain in words
I love that feeling I mean
with my family outside
it's pretty special
it must be what skid feels like to white
people I have no idea like they can love
it so much and I
think it's gonna be hard
[Music]
I come from a big family we're really
close and we love spending time together
[Music]
bread
grew up with Junior is
junior is like how I see him sometimes
it's like a hippie
Junior's life is so on the go go he
never stops he doesn't rest because he
wants to live life to the fullest
literally when he was a kid he was kind
of a little brat if he didn't get his
way he would cry a lot make scene
whatever Junior wanted he gets
um
[Music]
I'm from the Jensen neighborhood on the
north side of Houston some consider it
it's the ghetto but not really it's a
little up class schedule
it wasn't like go outside and play it
was
watch her back
Joy says
water growing up was huge
feeling like the power of the waves
it was where we were together as a
family
there's just a lot of laughter
a lot of joy
we don't know what we're doing we just
we're trying to fish so let's go for it
Mexican culture just values family
you know if you're lifted up like you're
bringing everybody with you
so the pressure being the first born
male in my family is very real
my parents expected me to just be
successful by the book
go to college get the big job provide
for the family start your own family
share the wealth
that was their intent that's why they
made their sacrifices
they wanted me to really take grasp of
the opportunities that our parents were
trying to provide for us
mom and dad like left Mexico
and now we're here
and you need to work harder than them
so yeah I worked my butt off
I think all that pressure to succeed the
way they wanted me to made me sort of
reject all of it
because they said I could do anything
and what I wanted to do is leave and
explore
to get to know this world is
[Music]
vodka
is
when I was deciding to move from Houston
I knew that Jackson was a pretty iconic
place to go fly fishing it had all of
the outdoor access that Houston didn't
have
fly fishing brings me a lot I think
that's why I like it so much it can
bring me a lot of emotional space
it Sparks curiosity
every stream has its own story just like
every one of us
[Music]
I had no clue what fly fishing was so
when Junior was talking about is that
this is something he's learning it was
very intriguing like what is it is he
actually sitting at a drone to go fly
for Little Fishies or what is it until
we actually saw him in action he sent us
a video of him just like flinging that
the pole here in Houston we don't blink
anything like that other than the lasso
from the rodeo
oh
when I first got to Jackson I think I
was a little blinded by the magic dust
I'm here in the most iconic ranges you
know in the states
yeah it didn't take very long for that
to sort of show its true face
when we went to Jackson to visit my
brother it was so quiet and very white
it was so weird
because we completely did not fit in
there
felt pretty isolated you know no one at
my job looks like me no one in any
outdoor activity looks like me
it was such a drastic change from from
my family in Houston and that being the
Benchmark for outdoor experiences
my community now I've been trying to
build one
I think since I was little I always
wanted to do something good for my
community
conservation work for me is about people
when I was working at my nine to five I
was trying to focus on the family as a
whole getting them to experience fly
fishing together do you see the loop on
top of the eye yeah
if the whole family goes out experiences
a place begins to love a place then that
becomes culture that's what lasts
and I think I'm really trying to like
create the experiences I had as a kid
for kids here
sauce
those days is a bilingual fishing
program that I started with other
Community Partners to get more families
of color out in the water and to
hopefully catch a fish
I think a lot of people are still stuck
on this singular model but it's really
about the entire family
and giving that opportunity to just be
for the whole family
[Music]
I've explored a variety of strategies on
how to change fly fishing I've tried to
do it through a conservation non-profit
I've tried changing it from the outside
with photography and film
the one strategy that gives me more
resilience is actually just doing it
just going out to the stream myself and
showing not only the people that are
already there
but people that aren't there that like
you you belong here too
now with fly fishing I'm trying to take
more friends out oh
that happened I luckily have two rods
now so I can show my friends
[Music]
Peter does what he's doing I've got
Rachel's butt which is my crappy raft so
we can go out in the water
so don't break your wrist you're kind of
breaking your wrist nice there you go
dude lose you are crazy is that they get
so surprised of how empowered they are
that they could do it too
and once they start feeling the Rhythm
you know everything melts and they they
really start to understand why people
fly fish
oh nice is that Hermione enough yeah fly
fishing isn't just for me it's about
instilling the belief in others that
they can be a part of the sport
so that the next Brown kid
can start to believe that he can do it
too
[Music]
I went from fishing the golf with my
family to fishing in the Tetons alone
with a bigger purpose
now I feel like the stakes are a little
higher
because I'm not just doing it for myself
it's really just my family talking
through me
but
believing is power
[Applause]
[Music]
he's not just in this bubble that we
live in you know he knows the world
we're extremely proud and we live
through his experiences
he's doing the things that we're not
supposed to do
I think Junior thrives on it that's his
natural state
to be that person that's not supposed to
be there so he's exactly where he
belongs
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah what about the Eddie what a
mountain
[Music]
thank you